welcome to ask I J no I need you guys to
just brace yourself for a second and get
ready for the coolest ask IJ theme song
cover
thank you so much he'll go Japan that
was so cool now on to the questions
turn acrostic I love stickies wants to
know if I can swim and actually I mean I
can swim just not very good I'm sure if
I had to swim to save my life
there's a good chance that I probably
wouldn't be able to do it if I could
have my own TV show what would it be
about it would probably be me just
walking around the street talking to
myself and getting coffee all the time
your poppy bean let me tell you what
it's so cool will is asking if I watch a
baseball and actually no I don't
well I love you yes poulard James wants
me to come to Toronto in June on the
10th through the 17th let me let me
check my schedule
Danny cracker wants to know if I like or
want children I have enough trouble
taking care of myself
let alone another small human being just
not ready for that but I wants to know
if I mind people copying me and dancing
at the Apple Store and actually I don't
mind it all more power to you well it's
my favorite thing to do at Disney ride
on the rides Paula G's in advance I
don't know how to pronounce your name
and you want to know if I were to eat
one of my electronics what electronics
what I eat I mean me and my MacBook
that's not good for your teeth
my mom would yell at me Katie do I like
cheese yes
Christian red apples the green apples
red I need to focus on this one this
person wants to know how do you think
you see my name Sivan smileyriley it
actually wasn't that difficult below as
I said it completely wrong
Heidi boo loves you I'm pretty sure
that's not actually a real name and a
facebook finds out I'm not gonna be too
excited about it what is my favorite
thing to do a favorite thing to do is
sleep and play xbox Olivia if I could be
any household appliance what would I be
I'd be the coffee maker Ryan McCabe
wants to know if I've ever smoked no I
haven't very jovial men wants to know
what my musical guilty pleasure is and
that would have to be Justin Bieber
except let me tell you what I'm not
guilty buddy the Bunge wants to know if
I can do this and actually no I can't
because number one I'm really dog
biscuits number two I don't have a ball
to put the dog biscuits on the good
thing you've already accomplished that
yes matter of fact that is too much snow
I'm so spoiled by LA weather aleem
Internet's I hope that's how you
pronounce your name actually I don't
sleep with stuffed animals but I do
sleep with way too many pillows
Pleakley mean you're a fatty episode
comment voila
if you'd like to be in a future episode
of ask IJ leave a comment below saying
Justine please put me in this episode of
ask IJ and remember this only applies to
YouTube comments so don't ask elsewhere
leave a comment and then maybe you can
have your little comments over there
thank you guys so much for watching this
episode of ask i J please like and
favorite and be sure to comment below if
you want to be in the next episode I
love you guys and don't forget subscribe
to this channel here if you would like
to get updates so you know when I launch
new videos and check out the rest of my
youtube channels here I know I've got a
few of them I have a problem it's called
I like to make videos alright thank you
guys for watching already said that I
did already say that okay